any book or tips to deal with depression
symptoms you don't need a book or a tip
to deal with depression symptoms Miguel
get a gym membership go to the gym pick
up heavy [__] put it down when you're
done go sit in the sauna and sweat for
25 minutes when you're done that go to a
dojo and sign up for some striking
classes for kickboxing for boxing and
then do some striking there's nobody
that I know that lifts weights or goes
to a dojo and fights that's depressed
it's only people that sit around letting
the news feed them all these all these
distractions oh the world's ending this
is happening this Invasion people are
dying over here civilians women
just turn it all off get a gym
membership get some exercise get the
juices flowing stop sitting on your ass
all day that's all you need okay you
don't need a book you don't need a
course you don't need a therapist you
need a
gym keep keep doing push-ups and situps
until you're ripped and you've got
sixpack abs and then tell me if you're
depressed yeah tell us what to do that's
what people want they want to be ruled
guys the join link for AMA is pinned at
the top the streamyard link make sure
you got a good connection in headphones
if uh you know if there's potentially
going to be feedback but just you know
you can check your internet connection
uh Collins will happen happen shortly
but again people want to be ruled the
vast majority of people want to be they
want to convince you like this dude over
here how do you deal with depression
right look I'm not going to say
depression isn't real I'm not that guy I
get that people don't feel good
sometimes and maybe they want to call
that depression but I don't know anybody
making serious Bank in great shape with
a hot woman or hot women in their lives
crying or depressed you'll never see a
guy sitting in a Lamborghini crying
doesn't happen doesn't happen you can't
[__] cry in a Lamborghini you can't
crry an exotic car it's impossible you
got a you got a face of Joy on you man
you got this Aura of like excitement you
have a pep in your step things are good
when you're doing something with your
life when you're putting yourself first
when you're making bank when your body
is is physically strong and not inflamed
and out of shape and fat and you're
shaped like a bear you feel good and you
operate good don't let them distract you
trying to depress you or to control you
or to rule you somehow yes you have to
do what you got to do you got to come to
an intersection the lights red you got
to stop uh you know you have a job
you're going to pay taxes it's
inevitable I I have to pay all my taxes
you have to pay yours I've paid enough
taxes to PVE a [__] highway at this
point in my life here in Canada but it
is what it is you see what I'm saying
right don't let them distract you that
sort of stuff I mean one of the worst
thing you can do is take ssris because
they just numb your senses right like
we've had um we've had a couple of gals
on the Ladies Night Show which follows
up after the UN Alpha and a few of them
have mentioned that they're prescribed
meds you know for their various
conditions I mean they're
just anytime you see these people that
are on ssris and anti-depressants
they're just numb they don't care right
like that's what they're designed to do
and that means that you don't care about
having sex you don't care about doing
things you don't care about much at all
it just kind of like zombifies you
and that's probably a good place for
them to have you at because you're a lot
more controllable and persuadable at
that point especially when they got you
on the prescriptions you got to be
careful with that sort of stuff all
right let's see what uh we got Willam
here who's gonna hop in what do you got
for me buddy hey hey so I very much I
very I very much like your approach on
um your thoughts on depression you know
like um like when you when you take a
look at the percentage of people in
rough areas of the world like Africa
Russia very cold or very hot extremely
rough conditions like almost nobody has
they're depressed like they don't drink
meds they they they don't so around you
know they work all day just to survive
you know depression is the luxury of the
rich world you know there's no meds
there's no meds for depression in Russia
or AF you know you know my my um my
granddad used to tell my dad this and my
dad passed on this wisdom you know he
said no matter how shitty your day is
basically somebody somewhere out there
doesn't matter how bad your day is
doesn't matter how [__] of a day how bad
you got her what was stolen from you it
doesn't matter what somebody out there
will trade their life in a second for
yours people have somebody like billions
of people in Africa Russia would do
this billions billions it's not Millions
it's it's hundreds of millions like
people in Russia and Africa in extremely
rough conditions in Siberia in Sahara
you know they don't have water they
don't have heating you know like they
they struggle every day just to survive
and there's zero depression there so
depression is the Lu the luxury of the
USA of the Europe of us people in you
know with higher incomes that can afford
to sit around all day doing nothing uh
having zero interaction with the outside
world and other people
just pondering around the they can't
afford to be depressed and so you know
like crying over spilled milk they just
can't exactly like uh there I I don't
want to get around this uh dude you know
his thoughts he controversial but I
click to share the screen and there's an
excellent 40 second video of sneo on the
screen yeah sneo and his thoughts on
depression is just 40 seconds you know
if you want to play it we can play it go
ahead play it go ahead play it yeah uh
just tell me if you can hear the audio
yeah everyone is
dep there's no way that so much of a
generation is clinically depressed to me
that's not possible there's something
going on but it can't just be that
everybody is feeling the same exact
symptoms there there's no way that
everyone here is clinically depressed
people spend 9 hours a day on their
phones people spend 5 hours laying on
their side binge watching man everyone
binge watches which is a symptom of
depression like honestly if you if you
10 years ago you said someone was going
to lay down here on their side on their
bed watching a laptop like this eating
junk food it's like are you okay is
something wrong with you you need to
speak to someone and originally my
thesis was that it's because everyone's
[__] addicted to their phones it's
all day long staring like this you know
social media constant updates it's
Studies have shown that getting an
Instagram like release a little bit of
dopamine in your brain and so the rest
of the world the [__] outside being in
the cold being your trees and [__] all
this weird stuff is not as exciting not
everyone is depressed there's no yeah so
you know sneo is an interesting
character because I've seen him say and
do things which are completely offside
that I wouldn't agree with but I agree
with what he's saying there
exactly yeah and it's part of people
being persuaded to care about things
that they don't need to care about right
like they want you in a condition of
constant distress they want you in a
condition of instability they want you
in a state of Reliance on them for
things right like if they're if they can
keep you relying on prescription meds if
they can keep you relying on a feed of
constant [__] whether it's coming
through your phone or whatever it
happens to be then you're more
controllable it's rich rich you know
what's awesome about you like um you as
a guy you could make much more money
selling uh blue peill lies to guys like
oh your books of affirmation but you
know you just go you know yeah sure the
love language books sold way more than
did but it's all [__] yeah you know
you know you just went with r through
you go shut up go to gym I I don't know
anybody that is depressed that goes to
the gym you know and and you just say it
you don't sell 10 books about nothing
you know that's amazing that's why you
guys should maybe join the rich
Community or or read his books because
he doesn't have he doesn't sell you lies
he could but he doesn't you know he just
says the raw truth and go to the gym I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're newer to the
channel make sure you hit subscribe over
here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out